Alright. It is here! Bard is now Gemini. Google’s
smart assistant AI has been updated big time.
When they unveiled Gemini, they showcased three
versions. Nano for efficiency, Pro that was added
to Bard that we could use for free, and Ultra.
The ultra that was the super interesting part,
their paper discussed that it is so good,
they think it might even give GPT-4 a little
competition. And here comes the best part,
oh yes we can try it for free right now. So,
where can we use it and what can
it do? Let’s find out together.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If you have an Android phone, you can opt
in through Google Assistant or download the
Gemini app and there you go. And if you have
an iPhone, it will come to the Google app
where you just hit a toggle, and it will be
right there. As of the making of this video,
it was not available for me, but they announced
that it is coming in the next few weeks.
Or you can go to gemini.google.com and just
use it from the web. The regular Gemini is
pretty smart and remains free, and Gemini
Ultra is called Gemini Advanced here and
is available as a paid subscription,
there is a free trial where all of
you Fellow Scholars can try it for two
months, and you also get 2TBs of storage.
Google has some advantages here as it can
integrate with your gmail account, can summarize
your messages, write emails on your behalf. It
also has access to your google docs, slides,
sheets and get information and do work on them. It
can also help you with your coding, can evaluate
your ideas, and more. It can do almost anything
that you would expect from a smart assistant
that works for you. And it is going to be right in
your pocket all day almost all around the world.
Initial experiments show that it can also estimate
the amount of calories from your
lunchbox label, and so much more.
I also like that it can try to verify the
validity of its statements from other sources,
this is a feature that has existed
before, but now I sometimes see
it do it automatically. Really nice.
Love it. And like OpenAI’s DALL-E 3,
this can also draw some beautiful images for
you too. More competition in that area as well.
It will be hooked into your
Google Assistant as well,
making it so much smarter. This is also great
because it will understand the context from
your previous messages better, something that
all major assistants struggle with these days.
As far as I understand, Gemini is deployed to 230
countries and understands more than 40 languages.
According to their press release, Gemini Advanced
is available in 150 countries and currently only
speaks English. Well, I tried German, Japanese
and more, and they seem to have worked.
And here comes the really cool part. From the
earlier paper, we saw plenty of benchmarks
that showed how amazingly good the Ultra
is for more difficult tasks like coding,
logic, reasoning, but we could never
try it ourselves. And now we can. We can
now re-run all of these experiments and
even run our own. This is heaven. Also,
competition against OpenAI is heating up, that
is also excellent for us, the Scholarly users.
I myself ran an experiment from the USA
Computing Olympiad, a task that they
call insanely difficult. Yes, this is the one
where you have to assemble the robotic cows.
One of my favorites. This task requires
a technique called dynamic programming,
and the size of the problem is huge, so the
implementation has to be really efficient to
have even a fighting chance to solve it. This is
something that GPT-4 was able to solve correctly.
So, let’s see Gemini Ultra. It starts in the
right direction, but unfortunately, not yet.
Now, when GPT-4 arrived, there was a huge,
155-page long paper that subjected it to every
single test that you can imagine, and some
that were really surprising, solving mazes,
mathematics, playing text-based games, drawing
maps, writing a full computer game and more.
And I am sure that the same will happen to Gemini
Advanced as well, and I cannot wait to see them.
I tried to look around and see
what you Fellow Scholars are up to,
and my first impression seems to be is
that GPT-4 likely remains the smartest
AI assistant for now, while Gemini will
have the advantage of being able to work
within Google’s ecosystem and connect
to your other apps a little better.
So, what experiments did you run? Did it perform
well? Did it not? Is it as good as it seems? I’d
love to know what you Fellow Scholars are up
to - let’s run some more experiments and let
me know in the comments below how they went until
the new papers appear. And they are coming soon,
so we’ll know so much more. I am really
excited for this. If you are too,
make sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon to
not miss out on them. What a time to be alive!